[Music]
for many managing mixed workloads in a
database can be challenging your data
engineers and analysts need access to
upto-date information to make business
decisions but accessing this data as and
when they want can impact your
application and user workload that's
usually bad let's take a look at how
Cloud spanner solves this with databas
boost spanner is a distributed
relational database that ensures
transactional workloads have strong
consistency at any scale with very low
latencies for reads and writs of your
data One Way spanner is able to achieve
this is by separating compute and
storage when you set up a spanner
instance you specify how much compute
resources you need in terms of full
nodes or processing units for smaller
workloads up until now both operational
and analytical workloads that access the
data in spanner would use the compute
specified by your instance size this
might have led you to size the spanner
instance to provide enough compute
capacity for frequent operational
workloads as well as less frequent
analytical workloads or you might have
limited batch and analytic workloads to
periods of time that had low operational
traffic leaving your analysts with stale
information with Cloud spanner data
boost you can now run analytical
workloads at any time without impacting
your users and without increasing the
instance size because spanner separates
compute and storage queries that enable
datab boost will use compute resources
entirely separate from what the spanner
instance is configured with no competing
for CPU or memory with your
transactional
workload let's take a look at how this
works with big query Federated queries
from spanner in this example I have a
database that contains a game's
important data persisted in spanner this
data contains Player information and
history of items bought and sold on a
trading
post my data engineer was tasked with
analyzing Trends and items that are
listed and for how much this analysis
would help the company create or modify
events in the game based on the actions
of players tailoring the experience for
those currently playing the
game to accomplish this the engineer set
up a big query Federated query to
spanner this allowed the engineer to
have the freshest data on
demand however they noticed bursts of
CPU on the spanner instance that was
impacting the overall player
experience to mitigate this they have
two choices either increase the size of
the spanner instance or use data
boost increasing the spanner instance
size is either a one-time increase or at
specific periods when the data engineer
is allowed to run their
queries using using datab boost is
simple they set up a new Federated query
connection and bigquery to use datab
boost updating a query to use the new
connection solve the issue and players
are no longer impacted because the data
boost queries do not consume CPU from
the spanner
instance the data engineer can now
safely run queries at any
time importantly they only pay for the
compute used by the data boost when the
query is run big query Federated queries
are not the only way to use data boost
datab boost can be used with any spanner
client connector so you can use data
boost in your ETL pipelines that
leverage data flow data proc or other
custom
applications in another example my data
engineer has set up an ETL process to
anonymize Player information and Export
hourly batches of item sales to share
with third-party Partners using data
proc and
GCS with data boost this ETL process no
longer consumes the spanner instance's
CPU leaving that capacity for normal
operational workloads data boost works
for any query that can take advantage of
the partition query API to read large
amounts of data for analytical workloads
more information on which queries can
benefit from data boost can be found in
the documentation Linked In the video
description Cloud spanner takes security
very seriously you control who has
access to use data boost using IAM
permissions by granting the users the
used data boost permission this new
permission only grants datab boost usage
permissions so all existing access
control and data governance rules your
database owners have set up are still
enforced queries that use datab boost
can be tracked using Cloud metrics and
audit log down to the query and user
granularity in addition to the benefit
of auditing data boost queries you can
set uses limits on data boost by user or
query for granular cost
controls with Cloud spanner datab boost
it is easy to run batch and analytical
workloads on your production spanner
database without impacting your other
database
operations in addition to workload
isolation when you use datab boost those
batch and analytic queries May complete
faster since they're not competing for
compute
resources finally you can enable data
sharing for everybody and not worry
about dba's pagers going off more
information can be found in the links
provided in the video description below
data boost is generally available so
please try it for yourself go ahead
supercharge your spanner database with
data
[Music]
boost